welche Auswirkungen hat denn jetzt
konkret für Sie die Abgabe der Panzer
die Abgabe von jetzt insgesamt 19 unser
Leos tut natürlich weh
und hat natürlich Auswirkungen auf die
Ausbildung und übungsfähigkeit auf den
ausbildungsübungsbetrieb im Bataillon
gut und wichtig ist dass wir noch über
ein Minimum ein Kampfpanzern verfügen um
unser Nachwuchs das heißt Richtung
Ladeschützen unseren
unteroffiziernachwuchs und Offizieren
Nachwuchs auszubilden
die Ausbildung am Simulator rückt
natürlich jetzt in den Mittelpunkt
hier in Augustdorf haben wir das Glück
dass wir Simulator Simulatoren für alle
Ebenen zur Verfügung haben das heißt wir
haben Simulatoren für die schieße
Ausbildung aber auch um Kampfweise das
heißt Taktik des panzerzuges der Panzer
Kompanie bis zum Panzer bei der Region
hier auszubilden aber klar ist auch ohne
Kampfpanzer geht es nicht wir brauchen
Kampfpanzer denn den Führerschein
erwirbt man ja auch nicht im Simulator
sie sind in ihre Soldatinnen und
Soldaten mit dieser Information
umgegangen oder mit der Entscheidung das
ausgerechnet von ihrer Einheit die
Panzer abgezogen werden
die Stimmung im Bataillon ob der Abgabe
der Kampfpanzer ist natürlich gedämpft
aber ich denke die Mehrheit der Soldaten
und Soldaten des Bataillons
ist sich darüber im Klaren dass es eine
klare Notwendigkeit gibt die Ukraine zu
unterstützen in ihrem Freiheit ja
Überlebenskampf und dass wir hier bei
der Union auch die Last nun zu tragen
haben die aus der Abgabe entsteht wie
viel Panzer sagen sie sollten mindestens
hier sein Sie haben es eben angesprochen
man braucht auch Panzer nicht nur
Simulatoren damit Sie hier weiter die
Ausbildung machen können um Soldatinnen
und Soldaten eben im Umgang mit dem
Leopard zu trainieren das Mindeste was
wir hier an Ausbildung sicherstellen
wollen und müssen ist die Ausbildung
unseres führen Nachwuchs Wuchses oder
uns das Nachwuchs im Allgemeinen und
dafür braucht's erstmal in Minimum fünf
bis zehn Kampfpanzer und dann können wir
den Rest mit Simulatoren
auffangen wenn alles voll wäre wie viel
Panzer hätten sie denn hier stehen ein
Panzerbataillon voll aufgefüllt verfügt
über 44 Kampfpanzer Leopard wie würden
Sie jetzt Ihre persönliche
Einsatzbereitschaft ihres Bataillons
einschätzen jetzt mit der Abgabe der
Panzer das panzerbarion 203 kommt gerade
aus dem Einsatz war von August letzten
Jahres bis Anfang Februar in Litauen an
der NATO Ostflanke eingesetzt und hat
dort seine Einsatzbereitschaft bewiesen
die Abgabe der Kampfpanzer gerade aus
dem bei der jungen Augustdorf ist auch
dem geschuldet dass nun andere bei der
Jone einsatzbereit vor allem an die NATO
ostflagge geschickt werden und wir
gerade aus dem Einsatz kommen
sind die Panzer schon unterwegs kann man
dazu was sagen also sind die schon
abgeholt worden dass sie sagen okay die
ersten sind schon auf dem Weg läuft ist
schon an oder ist das auch noch ein
langwieriger Prozess ist das dann alles
vollzogen ist also wir das
abzugeben Panzer in den letzten Wochen
vorbereitet das heißt
noch mal
sozusagen wie wenn man ein
Gebrauchtwagen kauft den noch mal auf
Stand gebracht
die wareneinsatzbereit aber ziel war es
sie im bestmöglichen Zustand abzugeben
und insofern wurden noch mal
Verschleißteile am Fahrgestell und am
Turm ausgetauscht und dann auf dem
Truppenübungsplatz die Kampfpanzer noch
mal angeschossen das heißt sie wurden
noch mal mit der wurde noch mal mit der
gefechtsmunition geschossen um dann auch
auf weite Kampfentfernung die
bestmögliche treffen Wahrscheinlichkeit
zu erzielen
und dementsprechend sind sie jetzt am
Endstadium Stadium der Vorbereitung für
die Abgabe und diese wird auf jeden Fall
bis Ende März sichergestellt diese
Situation das spielt dann auch hier
statt oder werden die dann für in andere
Abteilung geschickt um dann dieses
anschießen noch mal zu machen findet das
dann hier statt auf dem Gelände die
Vorbereitung der Kampfpanzer findet
einerseits hier statt wenn es um
Instandsetzungsmaßnahmen geht einmal
fürs Fahrgestell Kette Zahnkränze durch
die Soldaten meines Bataillons wenn es
darum geht größere Teile auszutauschen
den Rohr wie eine Nachtsicht Optik dann
wird das in der Industrie gemacht die
aber auch hier in der Liegenschaft zur
Verfügung steht und anschließend findet
dann auf einem der Truppenübungsplätze
in Deutschland statt nicht hier in
Augsburg
jetzt fragen sich natürlich viele
Menschen wenn man so ein Panzer sieht
wie schwierig ist das so ein Panzer zu
bedienen zu fahren was würden Sie
einschätzen braucht ein Mann eine Frau
um dieses Gefährt bewegen zu können also
wenn man Grundkenntnisse hat das heißt
ein Auto fahren kann dann kann man die
Grundlagen des Fahrens und das Bedienen
des Fahrzeugs sicherlich in eins bis
zwei Wochen vermitteln aber
diese Kampfpanzer sollen in wenigen
Wochen in der Ukraine im Krieg
eingesetzt werden und dann muss man das
Fahrzeug beherrschen das heißt unter
Stress und schwierigen Bedingungen damit
umgehen können
was würden Sie sagen wenn Sie jetzt
einen Wunsch frei hätten was sie hier
benötigen können was braucht die
Bundeswehr was braucht ihre Einheit
weiter an Unterstützung um effektiv
arbeiten zu können
wir am ersten Februar war ja unser
Bundesminister hier um einerseits noch
mal das rational für die Entscheidung
Kampfpanzer aus dem Panzer bei uns 203
abzugeben hier zu erläutern zweitens hat
er sich ja auch den Fragen gestellt und
drittens hat er natürlich auch die
Perspektive aufgezeigt dass es um
Nachbeschaffung das heißt Umsatz gehen
muss schnellstmöglich und das ist das
was wir brauchen